hey there's a new kind of explosive out
uh
i know you're probably not shopping for
one but i got a journal article this
week talking about
researchers at the university of
michigan lawrence livermore working on a
potential alternative to some existing
military explosives
and that's interesting to me
again not because i'm necessarily
shopping to blow anything up but because
i'm fascinated by this particular kind
of science so here's what they did
they took two existing explosives one of
them called hmx or i'm gonna try to
pronounce these just bear with me uh one
three five seven tetra nitro one three
five seven tetra azo cyclooctane
and another one called cl20 which is um
this one's my favorite two four six
eight ten twelve hexanitro two four six
eight ten twelve hexa isoworzetaine
uh that's all organic chemistry
conventions but what that basically
means is they have these two different
explosives with relative value um the uh
um the hmx uh has a detonation velocity
of like 9 400 meters per second and it's
relatively insensitive which means it
won't go off by accident the cl20 was a
little bit more powerful but also goes
off when you don't want it to it's too
sensitive
what these researchers did is they
combined the two they made a sort of
crystal uh sandwich layers of each of
them and when they did that they found
that they got a little bit
faster detonation velocity which is to
say bigger boom
but sensitivity of the hmx the way they
test this is great they take a little
bit of the explosive and then they just
drop a five pound weight on it again and
again from different heights and uh the
lower it is that the lower the weight is
that it blows up that's how sensitive it
is you want it to go off from a high
level nitroglycerin very sensitive tnt a
little bit less so
um
now uh why am i interested in this well
explosives are really fascinating
molecules they they all work in kind of
the same way um
you take tnt try nitrotoluene right
that's kind of the classic um that's
like a ring that's the toluene part and
then three nitro groups that's no2 and
when you give it a jostle
the um the oxygens sort of fall down
and grab on to the carbons and hydrogens
in the ring that's oxidation right
they turn into carbon dioxide and water
disappear because they vaporize and all
the nitrogens come together and form
nitrogen gas
so what you've done is you've gone from
having a very small volume of solid to a
relatively large volume of gas in a
really short period of time
that is a scientific way of saying
it go boom
the molecules book that i have says that
it goes with explosive you go from like
a gram of solid to a liter of gas almost
instantaneously that's an explosion
and they all sort of work like this and
these molecules all kind of look
characteristically the same i mean there
are variations and i don't know what
every explosive looks like but they have
these nitro groups right because you
want that nitrogen gas puff uh there
they are because they're organic
molecules they have like carbon rings
they a lot of them are radially
symmetrical they're sort of like a
pinwheel they look really pretty
i feel about these things a little bit
the same way i feel about like f-18s um
i was raised by anti-war protesters i
wasn't allowed to have toy guns as a kid
so i made them out of sticks
but the lesson basically stayed with me
i tend to be
a non-violent sort of person a a
non-war maker
but i
i like the
aesthetic isn't the right word but i
like the uh
the way
that we build these purpose-built
objects
i think that a fighter plane is one of
the most amazing things human beings can
build i feel a little bit the same about
aircraft carriers or even the m4 carbine
that soldiers carry um because
they are um terrifyingly of a purpose
they're made to do a thing
and that's why i'm interested in these
molecules too these are individual
molecules that are are purpose built
they
they combine in the most terrifying way
you can imagine both truth and beauty a
destiny to explode they are built to do
nothing else
that's elegant